if you follow education you're used to
seeing school reformers describe this
conservative meanwhile education reform
advocates tend to describe their own
efforts as centrist so which is it turns
out it's neither in a new study we
analyzed political contributions from
the staff at hundreds of the nation's
leading school reform organizations and
found out that they were overwhelmingly
Democratic by a margin of nine to one or
more this rivals the leans we see in
famously Democratic precincts like
Hollywood it turns out that reformers
are more uniformly democratic then is
the National Education Association a
coalition so wedded to one political
party will inevitably suffer when it
comes to forging alliances finding
converts or speaking to many parents and
educators its members may not appreciate
or even much care how their proposals
and rhetoric are received by those to
their right put simply a monochromatic
aliy blue school reform movement is an
unhealthy one do you think school reform
can be bipartisan when politics is so
polarized let us know in the comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI